♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO THE "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
DID YOU CATCH THE VP DEBATE LAST
NIGHT?
IF YOU DID ANXIETY YOU HAVE TO
THINK DIVIDE AND PEOPLE ARE
BEGINNING TO REGRET PICKING
KAMALA HARRIS FOR THAT TICKET.
MAYBE ON PAPER HARRIS MADE SENSE
AS A OLD GUY’S RUNNING MATE,
APPARENTLY SHE DID.
BUT ONSTAGE, NOT APPEALING.
UNLESS YOU ENJOY BEING LECTURED
AND SCHOOLED BY SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS WHO TRY TO MASK THEIR
INSECURITY WITH AGGRESSION, YOU
PROBABLY DON’T WANT FOUR MORE
YEARS OF THAT.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE DID LEARN AT
LEAST ONE IMPORTANT NEW THING
FROM WATCHING.
WE LEARNED HOW DEMOCRATS PLANNED
TO USE IDENTITY POLITICS GOING
FORWARD.
WE ALREADY KNEW THAT IDENTITY
POLITICS WAS EFFECTIVE, MIGHT BE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET
DEMOCRATS TO THE POLLS IN AN
ELECTION YEAR WHICH IS WHY THEY
DO IT.
WHAT WE LEARNED LAST NIGHT IS
THAT IDENTITY POLITICS HAS A
BIGGER PURPOSE.
IT’S A JUSTIFICATION THAT
DEMOCRATS WILL USE TO TEAR DOWN
OUR CENTURIES OLD SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT AND REPLACE IT WITH
ONE PARTY RULE WITH THEMSELVES
IN CHARGE.
THE EVIDENCE CAME TOWARD THE END
OF LAST NIGHTS DEBATE WHEN
MIKE PENCE ASKED HARRIS WHAT THE
MODERATOR DIDN’T ASK, BUT SHOULD
HAVE.
DO SHE AND BIDEN PLAN TO PACK
THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
DOES THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
PLAN TO CONVERT OUR THIRD BRANCH
OF CURRENT GOVERNMENT INTO A
PARTISAN SUPER LEGISLATURE WITH
LIFETIME TENURE?
IT’S A PRETTY SIMPLE QUESTION,
IT’S A VITAL QUESTION.
POLITICAL COURTS ARE THE
HALLMARK OF BANANA REPUBLICS AND
DICTATORSHIPS AND WE DON’T WANT
THAT HERE.
YET FOR WEEKS JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS WILL TELL MIKE
HAVE REFUSED TO SAY WHAT THEY
WILL DO IF ELECTED.
SO LAST NIGHT PENS PUSHED AGAIN
AND HERE’S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> ARE YOU AND JOE BIDEN, IF
SOMEHOW YOU WIN THIS ELECTION,
OWING TO PACK THE SUPREME COURT
TO GET YOUR WAY?
>> JOE AND I ARE VERY CLEAR.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE VOTING
RIGHT NOW AND IT SHOULD BE THEIR
DECISION ABOUT WHO WILL SERVE ON
THIS MOST IMPORTANT BODY FOR A
LIFETIME.
>> THANK YOU.
THE CITIZENS WHO ARE VOTING
RIGHT NOW, THEY WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW IF YOU AND JOE BIDEN ARE
GOING TO PACK THE SUPREME COURT
IF YOU DON’T GET YOUR WAY IN
THIS NOMINATION.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT PACKING THE
COURT THEN.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT -- I’M ABOUT TO.
DO YOU KNOW OF THE 50 PEOPLE WHO
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPOINTED TO THE
COURT OF APPEALS FOR LIFETIME
APPOINTMENTS, NOT ONE IS BLACK?
THIS IS WHAT THEY’VE BEEN DOING.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT PACKING A
COURT, LET’S HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
>> Tucker: WAIT A MINUTE, YOU
MIGHT ASK.
WHAT DOES COURT PACKING HAVE TO
DO WITH A NUMBER OF BLACK JUDGES
ON THE FEDERAL CIRCUIT COURTS OF
APPEALS?
DOES SEEM LIKE COMPLETELY
UNRELATED CONCEPTS.
WAS KAMALA HARRIS TRYING TO JOT
DOWN MIKE DODGED THE QUESTION?
UNFORTUNATELY SHE WAS NOT
DODGING IT, SHE WAS ANSWERING
DON’T LIKE ANSWERING THE
QUESTION AND ANSWERING IT
HONESTLY.
IF SHE AND JOE BIDEN WIN NEXT
MONTH, SHE WILL INDEED PACK THE
SUPREME COURT AND THEY WILL
JUSTIFY DOING THAT IN THE NAME
OF DIVERSITY.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS RACIST
FOR NOT SELECTING JUDGES BASED
ON THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT NINE IS
A VERY RACIST NUMBER OF
SUPREME COURT SEATS.
IN FACT IT’S A NUMBER THAT SOME
DEAD WHITE GUY CAME UP WITH A
LONG TIME AGO.
SEE, IT’S A RACIST.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THEY NEED TO
DIVERSIFY THE COURT WHICH MEANS
A SUPER MAJORITY OF PARTISAN
DEMOCRATS.
THAT’S WHAT THEY NEED TO TELL
YOU BUT FOR NOW THEY ARE NOT
TELLING YOU ANYTHING.
>> NOW LOOK.
I KNOW, IT’S A GREAT QUESTION
AND I DON’T BLAME YOU FOR ASKING
BUT YOU KNOW THE MOMENT I
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION THE
HEADLINE AND EVERY ONE OF YOUR
PAPERS WILL BE ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: DID YOU HEAR THAT?
BECAUSE AT ANY PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE IN HISTORY EVER USE
THAT LINE?
I FEEL LIKE ALL LINES HAVE BEEN
USED BEFORE BUT THIS ONE?
I CAN’T ANSWER A QUESTION
BECAUSE I DO ANSWER EVERYONE
WILL TALK ABOUT MY ANSWER.
WHAT DOES THAT EVEN MEAN?
TRULY WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT
MEANS BUT WE DO KNOW THAT NONE
OF THIS IS GOING TO STOP WITH
SUPREME COURT.
THIS SUMMER, BARACK OBAMA USED A
FUNERAL SERVICE TO TELL US THAT
THE FILIBUSTER IS A RELIC OF JIM
CROW.
IT’S A RACIST PROCEDURE AND ANY
SENATE THAT LIMITS THE POWER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS BY
DEFINITION RACIST.
THAT’S THE NEW STANDARD.
IDENTITY POLITICS IS THE MOST
POWERFUL POLITICAL WEAPON THEY
HAVE.
DON’T TAKE IT AT FACE VALUE,
THERE’S A PURPOSE FOR IT.
AND OF COURSE IDENTITY POLITICS
IS ALSO A HANDY SHIELD AND WE
SAW THAT REPEATEDLY LAST NIGHT.
AT ONE POINT PENTZ POINTED OUT
THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ATTACKED
AMY CONEY BARRETT FOR THE CRIME
OF BEING CATHOLIC.
HOW DID SHE RESPOND?
SHE RESPONDED BY DESCRIBING
HERSELF AS A PERSON OF FAITH.
>> FIRST OF ALL, JOB BIDEN AND I
ARE BOTH PEOPLE OF FAITH AND
IT’S INSULTING TO SUGGEST THAT
WE WOULD KNOCK ANYONE FOR THEIR
FAITH.
>> Tucker: OH, COME ON.
A PERSON OF FAITH NOW?
HOW?
WHAT EXACTLY DOES KAMALA HARRIS
WORSHIP EXCEPT FOR POWER?
SHE’S THE MOST SECULAR CANDIDATE
EVER TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
AND THAT’S NOT AN ATTACK ON HER
BY THE WAY, PLENTY OF DECENT
SECULAR PEOPLE BUT IT’S TRUE.
NOT THAT TRUTH MATTERS IN THIS
CASE.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF LAST NIGHTS
DEBATE, HARRIS WAS IDENTIFIED AS
A PERSON OF FAITH AND THAT’S ALL
THAT MATTERS.
THE PROGRESSIVE LEFT UNDERSTANDS
RACE AND GENDER AND YES
RELIGIOUS FAITH AS A MEANS TO AN
END.
THEY ARE IDENTITIES AND THEY
DON’T HAVE INDEPENDENT MEANINGS,
THEY ARE TOOLS USED TO WIN
ARGUMENTS AND ACHIEVE POWER.
KAMALA HARRIS CYCLED THROUGH
VARIOUS IDENTITY AS LAST NIGHT.
I’M SPEAKING, SHE BARKED AGAIN
AND AGAIN WHEN MIKE PENCE TRIED
TO RESPOND TO HER.
IN OTHER WORDS, I’M A WOMAN AND
THAT’S WHY YOU ARE INTERRUPTING
ME.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT ASKED, WHY
DIDN’T YOU TELL ANYONE?
WELL BECAUSE HE SAID I WANT TO
REMAIN CALM.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR,
HE WILL NOT RAISE TAXES ON
ANYBODY THAT MAKES LESS THAN
400,000 PER YEAR.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, I’M SPEAKING
SPEAKING.
I’M SO GLAD WE WENT THROUGH A
LITTLE HISTORY LESSON, LET’S DO
THAT A LITTLE MORE.
IN 1864 -- MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
AND SPEAKING.
I’M SPEAKING, OKAY?
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS THOUGHT
THAT WAS APPEALING.
WHAT WORD TO WORLD DO THEY LIVE
OBVIOUSLY IT WAS PLANNED.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS MANY ALLIES IN
THE MEDIA WERE IMPRESSED ALSO, I
KNEW EXACTLY WHAT, HARRIS WAS
REALLY SAYING.
I AM A WOMAN AND THEY WERE
UNANIMOUS IN THEIR CONCLUSION.
MIKE PENCE HAS BEEN MARRIED TO
THE SAME WOMAN FOR 35 YEARS
INTERRUPTED, HARRIS BECAUSE HE
IS A SEXIST WHO HATES WOMAN.
>> SHE WAS NOT OVERLY ASSERTIVE
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE DEBATE.
AND -- >> HE REPEATEDLY
INTERRUPTED HER.
HE ALSO REPEATEDLY INTERRUPTED
THE OTHER WOMAN IN THE ROOM
WHICH IS THE MODERATOR WHO AT
SOME POINT SEEM TO LOSE CONTROL
OF HIM.
>> YOU HAVE A REPORTER AND A
WOMAN CANDIDATE AND BOTH OF THEM
YOU ARE INTERRUPTING AND BOTH OF
THEM YOU ARE ATTACKING.
NOT A GOOD SIGN.
>> HE KEPT INTERRUPTING HIS
MODERATOR, A WOMAN, AND HIS
OPPONENT, A WOMAN.
SOME MAY FEEL THAT SHOWED A LACK
OF RESPECT.
>> LET ME START WITH PENTZ.
HE WAS PATRONIZING WHICH DROVE
ALL THE WOMEN CRAZY.
>> MIKE PENCE DID INTERRUPTED
DID DO THE GUY THING OF
DEMANDING AND GETTING MORE TIME
TO SPEAK THAN THE WOMAN.
>> Tucker: SO AS A SCIENTIFIC
MATTER THE CATEGORY WOMEN
DOESN’T REALLY EXIST.
NEITHER DOES THE CATEGORY OF MEN
BECAUSE GENDER FLUIDITY IS REAL,
YOU CAN CHOOSE YOUR GENDER.
BUT WOMEN ARE ALSO
SIMULTANEOUSLY SO DIFFERENT, IT
TREATS THEM IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
ARE YOU FOLLOWING THIS?
WHAT KIND OF ADULT USES THE TERM
MAN’S FLAMINGMANSPLAIN?
WHEN A MAN INTERRUPTS A WOMAN IT
MUST BE SEXISM, THERE IS NO
OTHER EXPLANATION.
IN ORDER TO TREAT WOMEN EQUALLY
WE MUST TREAT THEM VERY
DIFFERENT FROM MEN SO AS NOT TO
DISTURB THEIR DELICATE
SENSIBILITIES.
AND IT’S A SHAME.
IF IT WASN’T SO SERIOUS IT WOULD
BE AMUSING BUT THEY DON’T EVEN
FOLLOW THEIR OWN RULES WHICH
MAKE SENSE BECAUSE THE RULES ARE
INCOHERENT.
>> KAMALA HARRIS WITH A SMILE
PUSHED BACK ON MIKE PENCE’S
REPEATED TALKING OVER TIME AND
INTERRUPTING HER.
>> SO DID YOU NOTICE THE SMILE
THAT WAS ON HER FACE ALL THE
TIME?
AND THAT’S HARD WHEN YOU ARE
GETTING INTERRUPTED CONSTANTLY.
>> EVERY SHOT KAMALA HARRIS WHEN
SHE WAS LOOKING AT HIM, SHE
WOULD SMILE.
SHE HAD A SMILE ON HER FACE FAR
MORE THAN PENTZ EVER HAD A SMILE
ON HIS FACE.
>> KAMALA HARRIS WAS STRONG, AND
COMMAND AND HAD A HINT OF JOY.
YOU SENSE THAT THERE IS
JOYFULNESS IN HER SPIRIT.
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE
PARTISANS, OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROJECTING THEIR
OWN STATIC, HIGH-LEVEL PERSONAL
LIVES ONTO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU ARE DOING,
IT’S TOO STUPID FOR A GREAT
NATION.
AT ONE POINT MIKE PENCE TRIED TO
ELEVATE A LITTLE BIT AND TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
MATTERS.
THE HABIT WE HAVE ALL FALLEN
INTO, THINKING OF EACH OTHER AS
MEMBERS OF CATEGORIES RATHER
THAN AS HUMAN BEINGS ARE
INDIVIDUALS, CREATIONS OF GOD.
THAT’S HOW PEOPLE OF FAITH
THINK, BY THE WAY,
SENATOR HARRIS.
WHATEVER THEY ARE CALLING THIS
KIND OF THINKING RIGHT NOW, AND
TRANSSEXUALISMINTEREST SECTIONAL
WRECK THE COUNTRY.
MIKE PENCE TRIED TO MAKE THAT
POINT.
HE SAID NO, THE POLICE AREN’T
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST, IT’S A
FUNDAMENTALLY GOOD COUNTRY.
THAT’S A CONVERSATION TO BE
WORTH HAVING AND THAT WOULD BE
EDIFYING AND THAT DOES MEAN
SOMETHING.
BUT THE MEDIA IGNORED IT AND
THEY SPENT MOST OF THE NIGHT
TALKING ABOUT A HOUSEFLY THAT
LANDED ON MIKE PENCE’S FOREHEAD.
>> I THINK IT’S INTERESTING
TIMING THAT A FLY WOULD LAND ON
HIS HEAD WHEN HE SAID THERE
WASN’T REALLY SYSTEMIC RACISM.
I SAW THE FLY BASICALLY GOING,
SAY WHAT?
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING.
>> Tucker: IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING.
WHAT YOU HAVE SO OFTEN IS YET
ANOTHER UNHAPPY RICH LADY
COMPLAINING ABOUT OPPRESSION.
NO WONDER THE AMERICAN
POPULATION IS SO DESPERATELY
UNHAPPY.
LOOK WHO IS LEADING THEM?
MOST PRIVILEGED IN OUR SOCIETY
NEVER STOP WHINING ABOUT THEIR
OWN LIVES, IT’S UNBEARABLE.
IN FACT, IF WE ARE BEING HONEST
ABOUT IT, THIS WAS ONE BRIGHT
SPOT FROM LAST NIGHTS DEBATE,
SOME ANNOYING BEHAVIOR ASIDE WAS
A PRETTY RESPECTFUL AFFAIR ALL
THINGS CONSIDERING.
CONSIDERING WE ARE THREE WEEKS
OUT IN THE MOST INTENSE
POLITICAL YEAR OF OUR LIFETIMES.
THERE WERE A HANDFUL OF MINOR
INTERRUPTIONS AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT BUT FOR THE MOST PART,
BOTH OF THEM, PENTZ AND HARRIS,
KEPT TO THEIR TIME LIMITS.
IN FACT THEY SPOKE FOR ROUGHLY
THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME LAST
NIGHT.
THAT’S WORTH NOTING AND MAYBE
CELEBRATING.
YET FOR THE MEDIA CLASS, THE
MAIN TAKE AWAY WAS STILL THAT
MIKE PENCE WAS A SEXIST AND YET
THERE WAS A FLY ON HIS FOREHEAD.
WE DEFINITELY DESERVE BETTER
THAN THAT.
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IS A
LITTLE OVER THREE WEEKS FROM NOW
AND WE STILL HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS
GOING TO WIN.
BUT THERE’S ONE THING FOR
CERTAIN, THIS COUNTRY